[Music]
since the franchises reboot in 2013
we've been excited for Crystal Dynamics
next Tomb Raider game the last game
showed heroine Lara Croft facing
impossible odds odds that would
eventually inspire her to seek adventure
now with Rises the Tomb Raider we get
the chance to see Lara come into her own
and watch her grow into the hardcore
archaeologist she's destined to be we
sat down with the game's director brain
Horton to talk about the changes to Lara
and her world which already sound like
huge improvements over the last game
players have more tools available to
them and facing a situation including
new traversal areas like trees and water
objects in the environment that can be
crafted into weapons and an expanded
skill tree that allows you to customize
Lara to your own unique combat
we've really wanted to build on the
foundation that we had in Tomb Raider
2013 and we had a combination of
straight-up action and we called it pre
combat or light stealth so a lot of
people responded very well to that and
we doubled down on it we came up with
what we call the guerrilla combat style
and that includes new traversal
mechanics like climbing on trees or
swimming underwater to evade detection
and also to perform the silent kills
from from above below
the other thing we've added in guerrilla
combat are a lot more tools and
makeshift weapons so you're gonna see
bottles and cans in the world those
things that can be used for distractions
but they also be crafted and used as
weapons so the it's the combination of
being able to use your traversal use
your mobility and get the upper hand on
the enemy combatants and then creating
distractions and chaos with the weapons
and tools that you have in the world we
wanted to make sure the player at
anytime had a strategic choice and they
can look at the situation and make a
decision either based on their play
style or how they wanted to go about it
if they're low on resources and they
want to get through a section they can
go completely stealth and not be seen
we've increased the amount of things in
the world that you can collect so we try
to make them as contextualise as
possible for for the bows you can you
can collect cloth and you can collect
wood and you can collect mushrooms these
different things can be crafted in
different formulas to create very cool
ammunition like the poison arrow being
one of them not only can you make a
poison arrow but you can make well you
know a skill upgrade you can make a
poison bomb so you can take get a corpse
you can create this this poison bomb on
the corpse and it will attract an enemy
AI to it or make a beeping sound and
then it'll explode right when they come
up to it it's all systemic we try as
much as possible to give the combat
designers an AI that allows them to
craft scenarios and situations not
setups and and there are moments where
you want to have a very clear this
happens then that happens but there's
also moments where we want them to be on
patrol patterns and and going through
what we call a need system that they
have a need to want to go to see a
location or if it's raining that they
might want to get into shelter that
makes the AI feel a lot more responsive
and reactive to the world
mobility was the foundation of Tomb
Raider 2013 our cover system was what we
called fluid cover so she would never
get stuck to a surface she could just
contextually crouched near cover
surfaces but now we've increased that we
have the ability to be up in the trees
and being bushes can be underwater all
of these have certain ability to get the
top of the enemy's awareness cones
but once again you can make noises and
you can pop that bubble and then a I
will be aware of you those bushes will
no longer be a valid hiding spot
we want to encourage creativity and
improvisation if they want to go
vertical they can do that if they wanted
to take a low path they can so we really
want to open up the play space let the
player observe the patterns of the a I
see what they're doing and make
adjustments to to get through that the
sequence the way they want to
this is the most metal gear we've ever
seen Lara Croft we're watching her
become the Tomb Raider using both her
archaeological smarts and physical
prowess to solve puzzles overcome
obstacles and become a true force to be
reckoned with there are so many ways to
attack situations giving players the
opportunity to tailor their play style
stealth all the way or running gun
alright
Tomb Raider you've set our expectations
extremely high let's see if you can rise
to the occasion